- Hey everyone, I hope
you're having an amazing day.
It's Mark Weins.
I am in Goiania in the state of Goias
in Central Western Brazil.
We're gonna especially focus today
on a local fruit called pequi
which is a semi-dangerous fruit,
but it's loved in this region.
It's one of those fruits that
you either love or you hate,
and it's gonna be my first time to try it.
I can't wait to try it out.
We're starting at the market.
We're gonna walk around,
we're gonna eat some snacks,
we're gonna get a feel for the city.
Then we're gonna go to lunch.
It's a little drive away to the,
it's a place called Goias Vale,
and then we're gonna come
back and eat some street food.
So, that's the plan for today.
It's gonna be an incredible
day of unique food,
exploring the fruit.
(upbeat music)
(speaking in foreign language)
- Good morning, man.
- Good morning.
(speaking in foreign language)
- [Mark] How are you today?
- Good, good, and yourself?
- [Mark] Awesome.
- You're here, Mercado Central in Goiania,
and a lot of handcrafts, local food,
and we're gonna see like,
which fruits are available,
and we're gonna try the empadao.
- Step into the market immediately greeted
by an abundance of produce.
There's cheeses, there's greens,
there's both fresh things,
but then they also have
pre-cooked food here as well.
- [Guilherme] This is a pequi chili sauce.
- It's such a like,
spacious, wide alley market.
Oh, here's some of the clay pots,
and clay pots are very
important for cooking in Brazil.
Cooking in this region,
the local traditional food.
- [Guilherme] The guy
here said it's strong.
(speaking in foreign language)
That's the empadao.
- That's awesome, that's huge.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] We'll just get the big one.
- [Guilherme] Chicken
sausage, onions, tomatoes.
- [Mark] So that's the one
with all the different meats.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Awesome.
You take a yellow bar stool,
and it's all just countertop seating.
You're seated right in front
of the case of empadaos.
This one's like, a super-size one,
which is the state of Goia style,
which is, there's meat in here,
a variety of different sausages.
Guilherme just opened it up
and added some of that chili sauce.
The chili sauce looks unbelievably good.
Mmm.
Oh, yeah.
Got a good bit of that chili sauce,
which has a wonderful
like, sour spiciness to it.
Almost like a meat stew in the center.
That's delicious and hearty.
The next one that we're gonna
try is the frango pequi,
which is the, it's chicken with
the fruit, the pequi fruit.
Mmm.
Oh dude, I could like, taste it, in like,
the fumes before I took a bite.
That does have an amazing
like, pungent flavor.
Cheesy, very tropical.
Very, very tropical, like, immediately,
you taste like, like jungle.
(upbeat Latin music)
I cannot overemphasize how good
the chili sauces are in Brazil.
This one is with guariroba,
which is a type of heart of palm, right?
- Yes.
- It's another thing
I've never tried, heart of palm.
This type of heart of palm.
(speaking in foreign language)
Oh yeah, oh yeah, it does,
you taste a little bit of bitterness,
and it sort of has the
texture of bamboo shoots.
(upbeat Latin music)
- Jatoba.
- We're stopping by another fruit shop.
This, he has a bunch of different fruit.
Some of them are kind of
like, dry in like, pots.
The fruit that we're gonna try is jatoba,
which is, it looks, yeah, it's
kind of like a hard shell.
He has to crack it open.
(pounding)
(speaking in foreign language)
- [Guilherme] Okay, this is good, Mark.
- It feels like fossilized
powder, like, in a pod.
Wow.
It smells like, like
almost like powdered milk.
(speaking in foreign language)
Oh. (laughs)
Wow. (laughs)
It tastes like powdered
milk, but with like a,
it turns to like, cream when
it mixes with your saliva.
Maybe the type of fruit
that you would really make something with,
rather than like, just snack on it.
But that is
man, I love tasting new fruits.
New fruits to me that
I've never tried before.
Oh, yeah.
Don't take too big of a bite
or you'll have a dry mouth.
It's almost like bread.
(speaking in foreign language)
- We have, we have this.
- Oh, this is a baru?
- Yeah, look.
(speaking in foreign language)
- Mmm.
Oh, this is the, that's
the seed inside of it.
Oh, wow.
Yeah, you can hear it rattling around.
But that tastes, that tastes,
yeah, it's very sweet.
Kind of like leathery, and
has a raisin taste to it.
We gotta move though because we gotta go.
We're gonna, from here, we're
gonna take a two-hour drive
to an amazing family local restaurant.
All right.
(upbeat Latin music)
(motorcycle humming)
Is that the place?
- [Guilherme] Yeah.
Aruana.
(upbeat Latin music)
- That was a beautiful drive.
That took about two hours.
We arrived to the old city.
We're right in the
historic center of Goias,
and this is a beautiful city.
It's not even cobblestone,
but these are like,
straight stone slab roads.
There's a church, the
buildings, it's gorgeous.
I love how there's just massive trees
even in the middle of the road.
This is like, the center town square.
We're gonna go straight to go
eat because it's lunchtime.
It's so incredibly beautiful.
The streets, the
construction, the heritage.
I'm just loving the walk even
to get to the restaurant.
Micah is having a roller coaster ride.
(wheels clattering)
This is the spot, Restaurante Braseiro,
and they're known for their traditional,
just a home, traditional,
this is the type of restaurant
I get psyched about.
(speaking in foreign language)
The owner is so friendly.
Thank you so.
(speaking in foreign language)
An amazing restaurant.
You can immediately smell the smoke
because they cook over
fire all of the dishes.
(speaking in foreign language)
(chuckles) Oh, yes!
Coming back into the kitchen
where they have the
entire stove is burning,
all, everything is cooked over wood.
Some things are cooked in big,
giant, like, iron kettles.
Others are cooked in clay.
These are just local, local
dishes cooked with love.
It's beautiful.
(speaking in foreign language)
- [Guilherme] She's gonna cook for us
the pequi.
- Yes!
- [Guilherme] She didn't wanna
cook today with the heat.
I said we're here for the pequi.
(speaking in foreign language)
And she goes no,
we gotta cook.
(speaking in foreign language)
- Oh, I am loving this place.
The food, you get all the aromas,
and actually, one of the main
dishes we wanted to eat here
is the pequi, which is the fruit,
but they didn't make it
today, but she is so nice.
She said she's gonna
make us some pequi now.
(speaking in foreign language)
Is it okay to taste?
Wow.
(food sizzling)
That is the pequi, pequi
fruit that she just took out,
and she's gonna boil it.
She just put it into a pot right now.
That's gonna boil.
I'm not sure what she's
gonna make exactly,
but that is the fruit,
that is the unique fruit.
Oh, it's just beautiful, like,
the orange and yellow colors of it.
Oh, so just don't dig
deep, don't dig deep.
- It's like, when you eat
like, a rabbit, you know?
Look.
- Ah, okay.
- You just use the teeth to like,
like a rodent animal, right?
(speaking in foreign language)
- But it's a dangerous fruit.
You can't bite into the
whole fruit or the spikes,
the little spikes from what I understand,
will like, stick to your tongue.
Okay, here it goes, my first time.
You're just kind of, like.
Yeah!
Mmm.
Oh wow, yeah.
You gotta just like, nibble.
I'm being a little cautious, just kind of,
taking the outside flesh.
It tastes like string
cheese, cheese on seed.
You wanna like, bite
the entire thing, but,
that would be bad news.
That's great, though.
It's so like, oily, too.
Even on my fingers, you can feel like,
almost like, avocado oil.
And then, if you get into
it, Guilherme is opening one.
You can see like, the
little like, spikes in it.
Oh, yeah.
You do not wanna mess with that.
That will like, actually
stick to your tongue.
- Oh yeah, it will.
- Sharp.
As we're waiting for the pequi,
the owner has blended us a,
this is a cashew fruit smoothie.
I've eaten the cashew fruit before,
but I've never had a smoothie of it.
You can see, she also garnished it
with a little cashew fruit on the side,
like a miniature, a mini one.
This is, it's gorgeous.
It's bubbling, it's frothy.
Oh. (chuckles)
Oh, wow.
That has like, a sour
strawberry taste to it.
Slightly like, alcoholic taste to it,
and it does have that,
but it's almost like,
strawberry-like.
That's, that's incredible.
- That is not water.
This is homemade sugarcane alcohol.
- The owner of the restaurant
really wants us to taste
his sugarcane liquor.
Ooh, yeah.
That's strong.
And then you chase it with
the cashew, the cashew fruit.
Mmm.
Yeah, that's like, really strong,
followed by like, really sour.
It is almost like strawberry-like.
- [Crew] It's strong, but
it also, it smells nice.
(upbeat Latin music)
- She boiled the pequi for
at least like, 30 minutes.
Then, she added it to the chicken.
She added it to the chicken.
You really, you could smell
that aroma, cheesy fruitiness.
They look like little egg yolks.
(food bubbling)
Her name is Casimira.
Casimira,
she is an amazing cook.
(Casimira laughs)
She's the main cook
here, she's so friendly.
She is, she is taking care of us,
and the dish is almost ready.
It's unbelievably fragrant.
I am ecstatic to try it.
(food bubbling)
Another dish that I just smelled
over here, bubbling away,
this is a preserved
like, like, smoked meat.
It smells so good, and I can almost,
I think there must be
like, some sugar in there.
The sauce looks almost like caramely.
(speaking in foreign language)
- [Guilherme] And you just
slice off a piece with a fork.
(speaking in foreign language)
- Oh! (chuckles)
(dog barking)
Before we dig into the main dish,
she wanted us to try this beef,
which has been simmering in that pot.
Such pure beef!
It's so lean.
(speaking in foreign language)
Okay.
Let's get started with the full meal.
It's all buffet, self-service.
So, even, you even, they have
some salads at the front,
but you even come to the kitchen,
where the dishes are
still cooking and heating,
to serve yourself.
I'm going rice first
because this is what you wanna
lay your base down before,
before you dig into the pequi stew.
Yeah, the main dish I
really wanna eat right now
is the pequi stew,
so I'm gonna get some
of the chicken first.
Some pieces of chicken on there, pequi.
You accidentally forget that it's a pequi
and just chomp down on the whole thing,
you would actually like, suffer.
And then, just drizzle it, and sauce it.
I'm gonna move over here
to some of the beans.
Like, really sticky, really hearty beans.
Oh, the stickiness of that.
Bean stew with, this
looks like pork hearts.
(gasping)
(upbeat Latin music)
One meatball.
Meatball on the side here.
Oh, what is that?
Kind of like, almost lasagna-y,
but it's more like enchilada style.
On the side there.
(speaking in foreign language)
Okay.
I think it's okra.
- It's okra.
- There's also the salads,
but I think I'll have to wait
for round two for salads.
(upbeat Latin music)
So excited!
I got a variety of the different dishes,
but that, yeah, that main dish
is the pequi with the chicken stew.
You can, like, as you're
carrying your plate around,
like, the entire restaurant
can just smell of the fruit.
It kind of, I was just trying
to think what it smells like.
It does kind of smell like jackfruit.
It kind of has almost a, like
a overly pungent banana aroma.
I'm gonna first just taste
the rice with the pequi sauce
that she boiled out.
Oh, yes.
It's so unique.
Like, it's a salty chicken
stew that has a really like,
like, kind of, like, chicken
peppery broth taste to it,
but then with that like,
fruity, jackfruity taste.
They do kind of look like egg yolks,
but they are far from egg yolks.
People do say it is a dangerous fruit
because you gotta know.
If you don't know and you
just take a bite of it,
you're like, in real serious trouble.
Like, you could, your
tongue might be in danger
of never tasting again.
Like. (muffled speaking)
Oh, wow!
When it's cooked, it's almost like,
it almost takes on more of
a starchy, oh! (chuckles)
Like, hardened cheese,
but like, with a banana,
like a pungent banana taste.
It's kind of creamy.
Almost like the texture of a
bean now that it's been cooked.
You don't wanna get too overly
excited about eating this.
Because it's so delicious,
and then end up with a,
with a tongue
that's just like, your
tongue's torn apart.
That's all I should know,
that's unbelievably unique.
When you touch it with your fingers,
it feels like avocado oil.
It has to be healthy.
To the beans and the feijoada,
and I think that's pork skin,
chunks of pork skin in there too.
(laughing)
(upbeat Latin music)
Dude, that pork skin
just melts in your mouth,
and with those starchy
beans, pure home cooking.
And you taste the fire in it as well.
And I got a piece of sausage in here too.
Beans and rice.
What a, what a combination of love.
(upbeat Latin music)
That roll of dough with meat
inside and tomato sauce.
(upbeat Latin music)
Feels like a noodle wrapper,
but it's more of like a pancake.
Minced meat in the middle
with a very vibrant tomato sauce.
- Be careful,
be careful with the pequi.
- Yeah.
You two handled it well.
(laughs)
True, but the flavor is
just, it's unbelievably good.
- Yes.
- Like, it's so unique.
(upbeat Latin music)
Hearty food.
Okay, I'm going to try some of the juices
that the owner just brought us.
(speaking in foreign language)
Not sure what this one is,
but it's a green juice, a local fruit.
Mmm.
Oh, that tastes like soursop.
- The name, cagaita.
- Cagaita.
- Yeah, I have no clue
how to say it in English.
- (laughs) Neither do I.
- Because there's some
fruits, Brazilian fruits,
for example, jabuticaba,
there's no meaning.
And you just say, jabuticaba, you know.
- It originates here, it's from here.
- Yes.
- And it's like,
it's just where you have to try it.
It's kind of like, minty,
kind of like soursop-y.
Delicious.
Okay, next juice is the caja.
Oh.
That's like, it tastes like marian plum,
like a stronger mango.
Mmm.
Wow.
And like, almost like,
apricot at the same time.
Last juice is the tamarind juice.
(slurps)
Oh!
Oh, that's amazing.
And I've had tamarind like,
countless, countless times,
in so many things,
but this is really good,
the way she's made it.
It's extra sour, and just
balanced to a sweetness.
(upbeat Latin music)
Okay, add a little chilies, you know,
going for that meatball next.
(upbeat Latin music)
Mmm.
Oh!
The meatball.
It's just like, solid, condensed meat
with a very fine grind.
Went back for some vegetables.
I got some, I think it's green zucchini.
I think it's green zucchini
but I'm not totally sure.
(Guilherme Laughs)
I think so.
- Yeah.
- Okay, final pequi.
(upbeat Latin music)
You gotta, yeah, you have to
nibble on it like a rabbit.
That actually tastes like cheddar cheese.
(speaking in foreign language)
Amazing.
Thank you.
(speaking in foreign language)
Thank you so much.
Amazing, amazing.
Thank you, thank you.
(speaking in foreign language)
That was a spectacular meal.
And she is so nice, Anna.
She took care of us.
She calls us all by name here.
Yeah. (laughs)
It's amazing.
And also.
(speaking in foreign language)
Oh, man.
That was special.
(speaking in foreign language)
So special, an honor to be here.
(Mark and Anna laughing)
Yes.
(speaking in foreign language)
Super cool.
We even said goodbye like,
probably 10 times before leaving.
That, just, the food, the
hospitality, the culture.
It will leave you just
smiling, walking away.
We're just gonna walk around
for a little bit in this town,
get a few more shots, just walk around,
just enjoy the peacefulness of this town,
and then drive back to the city.
(speaking in foreign language)
- Yes.
- For good after,
that means good afternoon.
- Good afternoon.
- Going across the bridge.
This is such a
picture-perfect little town.
And we're almost to the church.
The natural beauty, then
just how warm and friendly
and welcoming everybody is here.
(motorcycle humming)
(upbeat Latin music)
How much are the coconuts?
- Five each.
- [Mark] Five each?
(speaking in foreign language)
Yeah.
- [Guilherme] He was
replying like, how are you?
- [Mark] Awesome.
- [Guilherme] And then it's like.
(speaking in foreign language)
- Sorry.
It's almost like a, a
wine corkscrew remover
that he opens the coconut.
That's so fast and efficient.
(upbeat Latin music)
Oh, yeah.
Oh, that's refreshing.
That's so good.
Perfectly sweet, a little bit sour.
Under the tree.
This is fabulous.
It's called Igreja de
Nossa Senhora do Rasario.
It's so quiet, so peaceful.
The murals around.
Oh, yes.
It was an absolute pleasure
and joy to walk around town.
This is the old city of Goias.
And yeah, what a beautiful,
spectacular place.
Highly recommended to visit.
Well worth the drive from
Goiania in the main city.
We're now driving back to the main city,
and we're gonna have a few
street foods when we get back.
(upbeat Latin music)
(speaking in foreign language)
We arrived back into town,
and we came straight to a
place to eat like a tamale.
It's made from corn, and
this place is amazing.
It's in a parking lot,
a sea of corn husks.
They've gone through just a mound of corn.
And unfortunately, we
got here kind of late.
They're almost sold out,
but they literally, they just
had one left for us to taste,
so I'm grateful they had one more for us,
but yeah, this is the type of place
you gotta get here really
early because it's so popular,
it sells out.
(speaking in foreign language)
Ah.
- This is with the,
kind of like, drippings,
like a sauce.
- Ah, okay.
She, as I was logging, she
brought out another one,
so we got one chicken, one beef.
(speaking in foreign language)
(car motors humming)
- [Guilherme] In Brazil,
they call Pamonha.
- Oh, pamonha.
- Pamonha, yeah.
- Ah, okay, okay.
- It's kind of like
the Brazilian tamales.
We have different flavors, you know.
This one is kind of like, carne de sal.
- With the beef in it.
- With the beef.
And then this is the--
- And the other one is.
- The chicken one.
- Pamonha with chicken in it.
- And we also have the sweet
ones, with butter, with salt.
- Ah!
- Plain.
And it's a typical dish from Goias state.
So, these will be the dessert, kind of.
- These are monster, too.
They're huge!
So, this is a full meal.
- Full meal.
- It's not just for like,
a snack, right?
- Oh, absolutely, full meal.
- Originally, we weren't
gonna be able to have
the full spectrum of them,
but now we got a sweet
one, so they're warming up.
They have a full leftovers still left,
so we got now three varieties.
All right, we're gonna
try the beef one first.
Cheers.
- Cheers, man.
- [Unison] Mmm.
- Mmm.
- Salty, huh?
- Yeah, it's like salty, but it's like,
it's sweet corn, right?
- Yes, sweet corn.
- It's sweet corn
because it's so, very
sweet, rather than the,
the non-sweet field corn.
It has that immediate sweetness.
Oh, that's incredibly delicious.
And yes, that's a wise move right there.
Add some hot sauce all over it.
And then, you taste the
shreds of beef in it too.
It's such a balance
of sweet and salty.
- Really good.
Yeah, there's cheese.
I think this is curd,
curd cheese.
- Curd cheese in here.
- Cheese love.
- Oh wow, that's a whole like.
- [Guilherme] Yeah.
- [Mark] That's a whole string of cheese.
- [Guilherme] Start with the cheese.
I'm almost positive it's curd cheese.
- [Crew] Awesome.
- Mm-hmm.
Oh, yeah.
Mmm.
- That's curd cheese.
- With the sauce, it's awesome.
It's sour, it's almost fruity and spicy.
It's like, something so simple.
It's so flavorful.
- [Guilherme] Let's try the chicken one.
- [Mark] Let's try the chicken one.
- [Crew] Waterfall it.
- [Mark] Like, I'm actually
impressed how good it is.
Cheers.
- Cheers, chicken one.
- Oh, you're doing away
with your fork, oh no!
(Mark laughing)
- It's good.
(all laughing)
- [Mark] Okay, let's try
the sweet real fast.
- Sweet one.
Wait, it comes with cheese.
- It comes with cheese?
Oh yeah, there's a whole
stick of cheese in the middle.
(upbeat Latin music)
Mmm.
The sweet one is good too.
It's almost like pudding.
- Yeah.
It's like, my favorite.
- It's like, the, that one.
That's one of your favorites?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, it really is almost
like pudding, like corn pudding.
I'd say my favorite is the
beef one, but they're all good,
like, impressively good.
We have one more thing to
eat on this food tour today.
It's gonna be some grilled,
some grilled things.
(crowd chattering)
Totally bumping.
It's so packed, it's so
energetic, it's so lively.
The meat is just roasting away.
They have this unique grilling system
where they have two layers of the grill,
but one of the kebabs that
we're here to eat especially
is the chili kebab, the pemienta kebab.
It's like a chili which is
stuffed with ground meat,
wrapped in bacon and
grilled over the charcoal,
and it smells incredible.
Part Brazilian steakhouse,
part like, beer garden.
Just an amazing, vibrant,
energetic, lively place.
Really friendly as well,
and you could just smell the meat, like,
in this entire neighborhood.
(upbeat Latin music)
(speaking in foreign language)
- [Guilherme] Cow tongue.
- I've just been told to just
take a bite from the kebab.
That's the best way to do it,
just take a bite out of it.
This is a beautiful skewer.
Chilies, there's minced meat kind of like,
popping out at the top.
It's stuffed with minced meat,
and then wrapped with bacon.
Mmm.
Oh, that's amazing.
It's not spicy at all, but
the pepper is so fragrant.
It's sweet and charred,
then filled with meat.
And then you've got that bacon umami.
Mmm.
Good.
- Let's do it.
- You gotta try that.
(speaking in foreign language)
You film, you film yourself though.
You film yourself.
- Mmm.
Not spicy at all.
Really good.
- Delicious, all right?
- Delicious.
- [Mark] I know what we need to do.
Trinidad Scorpion.
Oh, yes. (laughs)
(speaking in foreign language)
Oh.
- [Guilherme] Kind of
like the bacon crackling.
- The owner is so nice.
He just brought over this signature dish
which is like a mountain
of pork cracklings.
Okay, and we're about to taste
the Trinidad Scorpion
chili sauce on that chili.
Chili on chili.
(upbeat Latin music)
Mmm.
Oh, it's actually not that spicy.
- [Guilherme] Not spicy.
- [Mark] Not that spicy, yeah.
- [Crew] Love those chilies, man.
- Wow.
Oh, wow.
That is just like, unbelievably crispy.
And crunchy.
Next, the rice plate with
those beans on the side,
and I think that's cassava flour.
Mmm, mmm.
Yeah.
Wonderful, simple.
Rice, beans, and the refreshing tomato.
I'm not sure if it's beef.
A little bit chewy but really flavorful.
It's a video.
- Oh!
- Nice to meet you.
(speaking in foreign language)
- Next up, for the tongue,
I'm gonna sauce it.
Mmm.
Oh, yeah.
The tongue is so soft, it's almost creamy.
(speaking in foreign language)
It's onions stuffed with minced meat.
Like kofta, I think, they told us.
And I think there's cheese
in the middle as well,
and then wrapped in bacon.
And they're like, pool ball-sized.
(crowd chattering)
There's cheese, oh! (laughs)
There's cheese squeezing out that,
that squeezed out the bottom.
(laughs)
Wow.
I think a little bit of
the Trinidad Scorpion
would be in order for this one.
(upbeat Latin music)
It's not really that spicy.
The reaper was a lot spicier.
(upbeat Latin music)
That's delicious.
Oh, wow.
We have come to the end of this just,
incredible day in Brazil.
This has been such a fun
day, such an educational,
such a learning day.
The highlight for me
was definitely the drive
out to Ciudado de Goias.
Honestly, a huge thank you
to Guilherme and Rafaela,
and I'll leave their links
in the description box below.
And also, if you haven't
already checked out
this entire playlist of
Brazilian food and travel videos,
I'll leave the link in
the description box below,
but we've traveled all around Brazil
eating some of the best food.
It's been an incredible
learning trip up Brazil.
So, go check out all
the rest of the videos,
and I wanna say a big thank
you for watching this video.
Please remember to give it a
thumbs up if you enjoyed it.
Leave a comment below,
I'd love to hear from you,
and if you're not already subscribed,
click subscribe and also
click the little bell icon
so that you get notified
of the next video that I'm,
I publish.
Thanks again for watching.
Good night from Brazil.
See you on the next video.